free guy stars ryan reynolds contains
big laughs and is the movie kova 19
bumped so many times that it became a
running joke but there might actually be
an undercurrent of existential dread
buried beneath this flicks feel good
surface these are the biggest unanswered
questions in free guy caution spoilers
ahead
isaac asimov's three laws of robotics
dictate that robots may not harm a human
being must obey orders unless they
conflict with the first law and must
protect their own existence unless doing
so conflicts with either previous law
the npcs of free city do not have
corporeal forms in our world they do
however have bodies in the game they are
also undeniably computer creations since
your average free city npc has a body
created via computer and acts on
impulses directed by a computer doesn't
that make them robots this is an
important question because if background
characters do not possess artificial
intelligence their actions would be
severely limited they wouldn't be able
to rebel against antoine thereby harming
their creator they wouldn't be allowed
to disobey orders like the girl in the
coffee shop does when she decides to
make a cappuccino free guy is a breezy
summer popcorn movie so it avoids
explicitly asking questions it doesn't
want to answer but if guy is the only ai
powered npc in free city the only way to
explain the rebellious actions of others
in the film's climax is to suppose that
his artificial intelligence is somehow
infectious
let's assume for a moment that the npcs
of free city aren't robots but living
beings who simply don't understand
things like life death and free will if
this is the case then the film's climax
in which antoine destroys the servers
that house the game with an axe is a
tragedy on par with the destruction of
alderaan we witness much of free cities
destruction buildings collapse streets
tear themselves apart and hundreds of
people flee for their lives we are
informed that antoine destroys every
server except the last one which
coincidentally houses guy and friends we
care about like buddy so let's assume
that he destroys 49 out of 50 servers
which feels like the right amount based
on the room we see this means antoine
kills 98 of the people in free city sure
antoine is supposed to be the film's
villain but this makes him a mass
murderer who slaughters hundreds if not
thousands of people who don't even
possess the mental capacity to realize
their lives are ending it really takes
the character to a whole new level of
evil but hey guy and his funny friends
live so why should we care about those
robotic npcs
i was created as a love letter to you
guy tells millie at the end of the film
you need to go find the author this is a
tremendously sweet lime it's also really
really messed up guys admitting that
every fiber of this being was
manufactured to love one person a person
forever out of reach
that's her
who
that's the dream girl buddy
let's assume millie regularly visits guy
via avatar what could be more miserable
than watching your soul mates grow old
with someone else now let's assume
millie eventually stops visiting guy
regularly what does he do now how can he
possibly find happiness knowing that any
woman he meets is destined to fall short
by creating guy as a love letter he's
doomed his creation to a life of
loneliness sure guy looks happy at the
end of the film but if there is a free
guy sequel the character's damning
mixture of self-awareness and
unfulfillable romantic expectations are
likely to plunge him into a deep
depression perhaps in a sequel million
keys could build a second ai powered
character who looks acts and sounds
exactly like millie allowing guy to
finally find love but now we're getting
into alfred hitchcock's vertigo
territory anyway free guy filmmakers if
you use that idea be sure to send us the
royalty checks
in what is undoubtedly the most
crowd-pleasing moment of the film guy
turns around a violent smackdown from
the newly uploaded half-finished dude by
selecting various weapons added to his
repertoire among other iconic items we
see captain america shield hulk's arm a
lightsaber and a fortnite weapon if you
go by his facial expressions guy
recognizes these weapons he also knows
how to use them but how could guy know
what star wars fortnite and the mcu are
and if he's so pop culturally aware why
doesn't he recognize his own story's
resemblances to they live and the lego
movie
what are these trick glasses or
something
it seems pretty clear that he's enjoying
the connotations of his weapons as much
as their functionality throughout the
film we never see any indication that
guy plays video games or watches
anything other than the daily news
report on free city's inevitable chaos
and destruction it also seems doubtful
that anybody would have spoken to him
about these properties since his peers
are equally clueless npcs or outsiders
who aren't in the habit of chit chatting
with guy before he becomes a household
name
free guy is set in two locations the
virtual free city and the non-virtual
unnamed city where antoine's company is
headquartered so what do they both look
like boston the word boston is never
uttered in the movie but we do see the
financial district the city's
distinctive waterfront the boston harbor
hotel and other instantly recognizable
locales inside the game is the game
called free city boston
no is it exactly mapped to boston nope
but there's enough boston specific stuff
present to make things confusing video
games typically either recreate a famous
city and use that as a selling point or
construct something wholly original this
does neither perhaps million keys are
bostonians who modeled free city after
their own environment but everything is
referred to in extremely generic terms
despite the landscape specificity
life in the big city ain't nothing like
it
of course free guy was shot in and
around massachusetts with lots of
important scenes filmed in beantown
proper but since the locations are
unnamed and no attempt is made to
acknowledge boston's people culture or
eccentricities the audience is left
wondering why the creators of free city
bother to model their entire game off
the hub
the next time you watch free guy keep an
eye on mouser as his nickname implies
he's a sneaky guy and he might also be
the machiavelli behind the entire plot
which one was mouser you ask he's key's
programmer buddy ostensibly stuck
listening to him talk about his love
life he's also forced to execute
antoine's evil orders finally he assists
millie on the sly without any apparent
motivation to do so this seemingly
unimportant character constantly
dispenses advice which milly keys and
antoine unfailingly act upon he shuts
down the game interferes with the game
and adds new elements to the game many
of which are unsuccessful but what if he
isn't failing in these moments what if
instead he's manipulating everyone to
his own advantage look back and you'll
realize that if a single character
ignored one of mouser's pieces of
information and or advice the entire
film would have played out differently
but he's so good at pulling strings that
all three characters think he's
operating on their behalf what's his
angle well mouser leans towards antoine
for much of the film figuring the odds
are in the billionaire's favor but when
the balance of power shifts mouser
becomes a good guy and lands a sweet gig
on million keys next project it's an
intriguing subtext for a movie about
avatars manipulated by distant geeks
mouser might just be the geek driving
the entire film check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite summer
blockbusters are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you